now
5 14 on your friday morning taking the
motivation ball and running with it i
mean that literally there's a proud mom
of two kids over at the macaw steam
academy in henderson she's fired up in a
good way
crystal dunning told me about the pe
teacher that rita goldstein and the
before school activity she started
almost 20 years ago called desert
trackers
crystal says kids crowd around the
school gate at 8 30 every morning so
they can get in and start running laps
until the bell rings for classes to
start
those laps are recorded on a card by
parent volunteers
with celebratory cowbell rings for every
kid who racks up 10 miles in laps
crystal says some kids walk and chat
with friends while others run their
little hearts out she says the kids are
not just learning about physical fitness
that she sees them learning that they
can do anything if they set their mind
to it
all right on any given morning you'll
see fifth graders walking hand in hand
with pre-k so don't get run over other
kids stopping to help classmates who
stumble and fall if you know something
that's cool at school let us know head
to eight news now dot com you'll find
cool at school under the community tab
or just send us an email cool at school
eight newsnow dot com and to highlight
ms goldstein's 20 years
one of the kids there likes to show off
his own dad's name on a back in the day
plaque over there where his dad was a
desert tracker 20 years ago that's so
cool
that's really neat it's amazing yeah
good stuff a lot of history got a lot of
generations here i think people don't
realize how many generations of nevadans
there are still here and teachers who
have the kid
who was a kid now is somebody's dad
yeah wow